thank you very much to better help and
Shopify for sponsoring this video more
on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it is I Andrew and we are here to do a
very famous film known as Elis it's like
he was right here in the room with you
yeah you thought you were with Austin
Butler right and speaking of famous I'm
with my brother from another mother
janito yeah man I almost cut you in half
that's from my favorite Elvis movie is
that with uh Kurt Russell nope H I
thought Kurt Russell was always a good
Elvis anyways we are here as mentioned
to do Elvis the buzzman one let us know
in the comments section what do you
think of this film and also we need you
to do those YouTube things hit the
Subscribe button Bell icon all
notifications and hit that like button
so you can let us know that you are
enjoying what you are watching also
special thanks to prepper they do such a
a wonderful job of editing down all
these highlights especially me cuz you
know I like to ramble on doing all those
references and all so full length
Reaction watch along where you sync up
with your own copy it's where you join
us on patreon it's where we call you
super sexy you get to enjoy the full
watch along with John myself you get to
watch the whole movie of Elis with us
also John and Greg have so many other
exclusive TV shows films that they watch
over there and you get to get all the
special references everything that I
watch Along on here that you going to
miss that are edited out so that's where
you really you know are going to miss
out if you don't join us on there but
without further
Ado any final thoughts John before we
get started no no man you're you're just
a hound dog Over Here Andrew let's roll
the thing let's go to Heartbreak Hotel
let's have a blue Christmas I understood
those references John alrighty let's get
into
[Applause]
it
perfect loc wowe it's a Bas lurman joint
baby yeah it's going to say truth beauty
Freedom
love
wow oh
my when it's got vibrant colors and it
feels weird you know it's puzz arm
Colonel Tom Parker snowmen League of
America you say one 2 is this a secret
Christmas movie for those of you who are
wondering who this fell here is I am the
legendary Colonel Tom Parker that's
right this has the the Tom Hanks
performance of a career lifetime yeah
right legendary manager of Elvis Presley
has been rushed to Valley Hospital oh my
God I am the man who gave the world
Elvis Presley okay thank you Colonel
Parker all because of you yeah oh damn
there are some who make me out to be the
villain of this history I mean some
people have said that you're the villain
of this
movie I'm very curious to see what this
performance
is okay fully going where no man's gone
before okay a cheat a con man a sh B
accuses Colonel Tom Parker I think
there's our answer oh my God Parker
received as much as
50%
inome many believe that Colonel Tom
Parker was responsible for the death of
Elvis Presley
no now you listen to me the only thing
that matters is that that man gets up on
that stage tonight it's all about the
prophet I don't care about the man no
The Show Must Go
[Music]
On
relax just a little pin prick that'll
get you going for the show I just
realized Elvis met Forest Gump he did oh
my God wonder if they'll cover that
moment are these all post
zooms
whoa oh that's
cool it's called karate man only two
kinds of people know the Chinese and
came one of them is me
[Music]
GL
oo
wowe that's sweat
boy
Maring
[Applause]
on Parker I'm gonna get a whiplash from
this movie
yeah is it still Christmas did the
spirits do it all in one night I could
change
no I didn't kill him I just took all his
money and forced him to go out there
when he was messed up nothing all those
mck rakers said in their book was true
me and Elvis we was Partners sure Elvis
the showman and the colonel the Snowman
bar
I always knew I was destined for
greatness as an orphan I ran away to the
carnival where I learned the art of The
Snow Job The Snow Job of emptying a ru's
wallet while leaving them with nothing
but a smile on their
face and the unique trick that gave the
audience feelings they weren't sure they
should enjoy
ooh tiating them I knew if I could find
such an act I could create the greatest
show on Earth this is the greatest
show after the carnival I moved into the
music business the country music
business it's a good contrast Carnival
is to music I like it sure you can't
have Carnival without music it's
true oh I know that actor what is that
dude's name uh David David it's David
winham isn't it is is freaking fair yes
farre Sun Records boy classic tell the
males of these towns that we need a
police escort for Hank when he arriv for
Hank going to have a Connie wedding at
the top of the ferris wheel at the top
of the ferris wheel that's interesting
and for you presents you are going to
march in the
parade absolutely everybody's got their
part man on an elephant looks important
holler still need to get a novelty act
to bring in the young folk why you have
a meeting with the duok of Paduka
tonight if we can book the funniest
mouth in the South we'll have the
greatest show of the let's go y'all have
to hear this kids all over town are
playing it everywhere I go uh what you
say what now I need to meet this man I
hear negro R but with a country flavor
oh cultures colliding and appropriating
makes all those race records with their
colored s this Fell's on the hay ride
tonight after me in the newcomer spot
see I thought Tom Hanks was going to
hear d doing that thing you the oners
yes oh yeah he directed that movie too
they are not putting a colored boy on
the that's the thing he's white oh shall
we play for the 27th
[Applause]
time there's no way that boy could be
white he's popular oh my God the way
it's filmed and edited it's very trippy
and acidy it's so white that shot what
are you talking about Andrew this is the
slowest movie I've seen in it's not
azman
[Applause]
filmes the dressing
room hey in the Blue Moon boys here
it'll settle your stomach what if I
forget the words on live radio all we
got to do out there is just a bit of Cl
and around that's right just make them
up SC and Bill aide you're not out there
on your own you boys are a band Teamwork
Makes the Dream Work and family is the
most important thing of all amen oh it's
about family Jesse is shining bright
tonight uhoh did the wrong Kid
[Music]
die Jess he now this is twin brother who
died at Birth oh uhoh when he was haved
in the womb by a machete my darling
you'll have the strength of two men the
10 grinches plus two my boy's daddy
passed a bad check and got cuted off to
prison boy and his mama had to take one
of the houses for white folks in a
colored neighborhood really that boy had
a big imagination he really believed he
was the hero in one he was going to
become the
flat I was thinking the flash too well
you know his dad's in jail he's got the
little lightning bolt and fly him to the
rock of
Eternity like how it said Rock The Rock
of Eternity
haha oh oh grab those moves them Comic
Book Heroes all have them superpowers
his was
music
ooh I love
it guitar too
[Music]
damn your whole world is being expanded
In This
Moment
oh from the dance hall to the
[Music]
[Laughter]
steeple
[Music]
oh my God I wish church was like this
grown up it's very somber Church
experiences my God who's on the
drums Elvis Presley needs to think about
his entire life
he plays he's in the zone
[Music]
man this is It's funny this is still
like a kinetic Montage but this feels
like the most breathing the movie has
done so far Elvis come on you got to get
on in they've already announced you on
the radio folks are real excited oh good
yes at fun record Sam Phillips was on a
mission to save the world by recording
black music but it didn't sell so to pay
his bills he needed to find a new singer
for his country act that's messed up
don't know what it is you see in this
boy whiteness mostly
different oh how do you know Big Boy CR
up big boy crud up that's all right Mama
that's all right with you that's all
[Music]
right
so he really is like like rock and roll
Eminem just grew up in a black area
learned Black Culture that's the perfect
close to the black experience as you
could be without being black or at least
that's what this is telling I I am
ignorant to the actual history so I'm
going to take all this as gospel
truth woo feel the Spirit my boy just
find how you s greasy hair girly makeup
oh I cannot overstate how strange he
looked this is the guy with the long
nose saying this it's the first
metosexual in history well I like to say
a happy I've been down here it's a real
honor for us to get a chance to appear
on lusiana ha ride we're going to do a
song for you we got out on Sun Records
you got anything else to say no I'm
ready tick it oh
[Music]
baby come back baby I want to play house
you oh sure get a
haircut ouch and kids if anyone invites
you to play house just say no in that
moment in a flash of lightning I watched
that skinny boy in The Pink Suit
transform into a
[Music]
superhero I understood that reference
Andrew's go well tell you baby what I'm
talking
about
to oh them hips get them hip
shots this is going to be a very Wiggly
reaction I can tell what they holler at
the wiggle them girls won't see you
wiggle move man do more
don't even worry about the guitar man
just wiggle it
[Music]
out sit down this is devil
music whoa we doing the Hard Rock Remix
right
now guys loving
this oo oh the guys are getting
jealous what were you thinking Jimmy
what were you thinking Jimmy he's making
us look bad is that freaking
Nightcrawler Cody Smith MCV Nightcrawler
not alen coming Nightcrawler now I don't
know nothing about music but I could see
in that girl's eyes wow she was having
feelings she wasn't sure could
enjoy how did you get cast as feelings
girl what was your audition like she
could have eaten him aive get him rush
the
stage oh my God we got his
jacket wowe A Star is Born it was the
greatest Carnival attraction I'd ever
seen he was my destiny right under my
nose oh in Memphis under my prosthetic
nose o from be Street to Oblivion I got
to I got to go to Memphis sometime along
with Tor and hand down and there's a lot
going on down Bill Street tonight
nowhere more so than at Club handy come
around if you want to see big mama
thoron oh look out big mama
thoron
[Music]
you
yeah
yeah louderdale
courts just why a truck driver from
Memphis Tennessee liked to hang out on
be Street I do not know yeah you could
figure it out hey squirrel nice shoes
leave the man alone he's the
king hey
Elvis ah the good old days where you
could leave windows down and door's
unlocked yeah that's that boy whose
record everybody's talking
about trap
[Music]
Elvis fascinating mix of sounds yeah
although I dig it I know people go back
and forth on baz you know
anachronistically crashing songs
together but he was crazy for that be
Street
music Goose Tatum I didn't take my boy
away from nothing he was running from
the day he was born sure was born to run
you quit your job to go traveling all
the way to Florida with this Colonel
fellow that we have never
met it's got an Entourage that follows
him I knew a fell once got his record on
radio it was all over in a FL I can't is
that Richard rockburg I can't believe he
played Dracula
and Van Hing I ain't ever going to let
us get back to a place again when Daddy
gets in trouble with the law put food do
not wear yourself out to get rich do not
trust your own godamn cleverness yeah
that Camel to fit the eye of a needle
rich man into heaven you know mama I was
thinking maybe I'll buy you one of them
pink Cadillacs like you saw back when
you was working at the hospital I don't
need no pink C I need a white
one sure I'm not fearful it being over
booby I don't know how to explain it
booby Hill but I saw it in that girl's
eyes it's something Beyond us but I know
that whatever it is it's something it's
something that can come between us oh
sure not my little baby no more and
nothing ever going to do that you're my
girl you'll always be my bestest girl
yeah I understand what you're saying
especially when you watch like movies
like Rockstar with Mark Wahlberg and
other things when you see what happens
to people when they yeah I totally get
where she's coming from She's watched
Rockstar 100 times def Almost Famous she
knows how this goes I actually have
never seen that one nothing nothing is
going to come between
us nothing is going to come between us
except all this right now
bet oh my God his Casino morphine mind
Palace is a fascinating
Motif there we
go
allar jamere our next four nights are
sold out thanks to the dazzling
performances of our tremendous Hank Snow
Hank thank you
[Music]
Hank got the crowd in an uproar
poor H rock and roll music is ruining
our
Carnival my
my ah he's catching up well I told you
all about him he wants to record one of
your songs oh which one all of it n none
of those L Generations sudden jerky
movements uh uh yeah about
[Applause]
[Music]
that oh no
I'll tell you this New Sensation Elvis
Bradley he is breaking hearts all over
the oh oh hello
there no what would Mama
think
wow I become a man
today that editing is
so
interesting well it must be like really
really mapped
out why you try one of these oh
no what is it pills uppers and downers
they're The Logical next step for you is
it a
quaalude yeah yeah yeah yeah you really
something else man I promise I'll put my
heart in I want to be just like you
yeah women want him and men want to be
him that's I want to be him
and I will do what needs to be done yeah
I'm sure he going kick you right off
this tour
dude come
Jimmy
[Music]
Jimmy a Jimmy you're Soul s your soul to
rock and roll Jimmy that night I
happened to see him
alone this Superman curl a snowman is
only as good as his attraction come on
man come on hurry up oh
no no your
chance oh
goodie goodie my favorite visual
metaphor
go uh Fame and Fortune it's all Hall of
Mirrors you look lost I guess I am the
Roar of the crowd the life on the road
and then calling home to your loved ones
pretending nothing has changed when
everything has yeah right I me I don't
know the way out that is precisely what
I am saying let's get an action scene
going now I saw you apart from all the
others burdened with Glory purpose I was
literally just I don't know how to get
out of this but I
do allow me to show he's got the cheat
codes to the Hall of Mirrors your future
Mr Presley blazing before you D
contracts television even Hollywood now
you're talking my language you're great
Colonel you are the best person I could
ever work with you know this is
something I I never said to nobody
before I believe I can be great too whoa
whoa
Pride goes before the fall but to
achieve this I need to represent you
exclusive what about hn oh damn he sent
me here to fire you wow he doesn't mean
I am your exclusive representation he
means I only want to rep you so I will
have to leave H wow we will both have to
make sacrifices we will need a record
label with National Distribution RCA RCA
RCA does have the distribution I just
need to know that you'll still be with
me as friends don't doubt that we're not
going anywhere Mary and I just don't
want to stand in your way that's all the
world needs to hear you sing Alvis how
huge you can make this little label
though yeah and they had his like best
interest at heart too H you to be free
of any entanglements uhoh you got to
stop seeing Jada pinket Smith is snow
business and the fans need to believe
that you are always available oh ain't
that the truth you might have to put it
out to that I don't have a
girl
no no we will need your parents' legal
commitment they need a bit of convincing
themselves Sam Phillips is a good man we
can trust we don't know this Kel from a
nail in a wall trust those instincts
have taken the liberty of making these
contracts out in the name of Elvis
Presley Enterprises a family business
Vernon PR ly business
manager oh man oh man what do you think
Daddy
oh talk to a
lawyer Proto sh's family to make sure my
mama and daddy never have to live in no
poverty ever again Mama oh it's going to
turn out so so good oh man oh
man girl I wasn't fooling when I told
those other kids I was going to buy a
Cadillac one day my boy with me you'll
buy them two Cadillacs it's always two
with you with me I I've always wanted to
Fly Fast faster than the speed of light
to the rock of Eternity yes Captain
Marvel Jr my favorite comic book hero my
man are you ready to
fly this is a fascinating conversation
but how long has the ferris will been
standing still thank as I said yeah he
knows the the Carney operating and you
know he paid him for that exact
time
[Music]
oh
hips heart
Hotel Heartbreak
Hotel it's like he's here in the room
yeah that first record changed
everything that's the house Forest
gumson right that's right his mama is
there too and then they're going to sign
up G Gump family
Enterprises it's another gold record for
Elvis Presley this one giving him his
first worldwide hit he was a truck
driver
damn come on let me show you how it's
the rags to Rich's story sure I took my
boys wigglin and put it in the movie
sure did I have not seen any of his
movies movies that's the next react
Series yeah your face on every
conceivable object
including bu of questionable
likeness G what what is the rules how do
you play Grandma you what is that behind
your ear a I hate Elvis the greatest
showman yes I hate Elvis in my way of
thinking I love Elvis that's an easy
sell those who hate your son will do so
whether we profit from it or not it's
not a bad idea
wow what is hate worth if it's
free remember that Mr L it's Milton
burrow the whole of America will be
watching absolutely so what is it going
to be how you going to blow that wigs
off Network wants me to do a ballot nah
I'm thinking about cutting it up with
hound dog woo yeah Elvis
Presley
Hound and uncle
strange things are happening every
day oh there you go Austin Butler like
oh he's really nailing the performance
oh yeah and he was nominated right for
this oh yeah oh he I think he won awards
for
this well deserved he's he's really
good all of Amer will be talking about
Elvis Presley they should be talking
about Colonel Parker yeah that's
right oh
boy oh you Awakening that boy right
there in the sweater
vest who the hell is that it's that boy
from memph it's your destiny what boy
from Memphis moving like a godamn don't
say
it of course get this smut off the
[Music]
airwaves pelvis what is that headline
about his pelvis
is obviously a means by which the white
man and his children can be driven to
the level of the Negro oh my god dude a
petition has begun circulating to Bar
Elvis Presley from telion we ey this
animalistic of gting while you're sing
has been bitly criticized I don't feel
I'm doing anything wrong is that an
actual shot of Elvis there Colonel you
put an end to your boy's animal behavior
or we will ouch don't worry Senator my
boy does what is told o cancel Elvis the
pelvis see cancel culture it's existed
for more than 50 years seriously Mr
Allen going to cancel me from the show
he is replacing you with one of the
country's greatest singers Mar someone
great oh the new Elvis
Presley just have to put on one of these
tals here can sing the H dog and it's a
light sophisticated family show oh no as
long as there is no wiggling of those
hips I can't figure out my own mother
approves what I do your mom's woke you
wanted to show the whole family can
watch and enjoy and we always do and at
this time it gives me extreme pleasure
to introduce the new elt
Presley the new and
improved updated recipe
so I mean he look like a butler he looks
like Austin Butler
he could have given us some more I know
how to do with skit I could have made it
funny the most stupid embarrassing
humiliating thing I ever what the hell
do you want me to do about it musicians
wow so did he perform it to the
dog we want the old Elvis oh my God how
far are we into his career exactly how
how old of an Elvis could there be
someone's got to think about keeping a
roof over her head we've always managed
to keep a roof over her head Veron daddy
is business manager it's his job that's
right um mama knows business too Colonel
has got us all of this I don't want all
this you're unhappy I'm
not you're losing yourself booby in the
music the moment the way you sing and
move it's god-given so there can't be
nothing wrong with it and I mean you
also got it from black musicians and
dancers and and other people too but but
God as well you ain't never happy no no
matter what I do no matter how much I
give you it ain't never enough and I
wish you would not drink so goddamn much
it's not good for you oh
my oh
damn taking matters into my own
hands no I can't escape myself can't
escape the image of me tonight handy
with sister Rosetta oh here we go
he got to go back to his
roots
damn he's signing autographs for
everybody if you're happy and you want
to be happy guess what you're at the
right place so just do me a favor all
hang
out all hang
out let it all
be you you about to pick up some moves
from Little
[Music]
Richard oh no what are these guys going
to do this you get the colonel to booko
Steve Allen yeah
right love his
moves best believe if you do you'll make
a whole lot more money than that kid
could ever dream
of that's the way the system works maybe
do it like like as a duet and record it
so that you could both be at the top of
the chart or or something do a feature
you should have your own label like me
you don't do the business the business
will do you sure enough I just leave all
that to the carel uh yeah that's part of
the problem cats buy your records
because they like what you do not
because you're dressed up like some
Butler no they like the colonel like
Austin Butler got to lay off the mov
says if I don't they going to put me in
jail that is ridiculous what's the
charge for busting a move in indecency I
guess too many people are making too
much money off of you to put you in jail
you don't know what you put him in jail
for you got too much privilege col's a
smart man there's got to be another
reason
yeah what do we got we found your
records unfit for military duty damn was
pretending to be crazy I wanted out I
was just a boy from huntingon West
Virginia of course
we found no record you at
all who are you from man but hey he's
not a racist that we know of so there's
that property of the vice squad oh my
God that is the irony whites only in a
show that is derived so heavily from
black music fans were cramming into to
see our show Senator Eastland was
holding a segregationist rally just
three miles away uh them Union Jacks
what uh song are you going to sing
tonight I made no decision oh look out
go with the feeling in the moment it's
been a lot of talk about the new
Elvis New Coke sucks and of course that
other
[Applause]
[Laughter]
guy that's a message to you directly
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things of course you got to listen to
the people that you love but in the end
you got to listen to yourself so I want
you to know those New York people ain't
going to change me none yes sir you
accept
trouble going you came to the right
place yes you did I was Bor standing up
yeah talking back
[Applause]
oh
yeah I have never heard this
song yeah no the hips the
hips oh yeah are these based on real
photographs at least the ones with him
in
them with
me
that oh Jesus Christ yes yes start
clubbing people that's right he didn't
listen to
me why why didn't he listen to me tell
him to be something he's not yeah his
heart said not
[Music]
to yes with what throw him in the brid
with
what devil music crimes of lust and
perversion yeah all that
dancing oh my goodness feel like that Li
was of disowning
sure feel like that looks of
embracement oh man the fuzz is mad he
had no idea
what he had done to both of us why
didn't he choose me I had to find a way
out a way to save
him from the president no way My Baby's
Gone to Germany for two years either
the jail wow in my way of thinking the
Army could be a brand new start for all
of us let them cut your head to world
you are a clean cut all am
boy chappie likes to paint since the day
he was born she had feared losing her
second son she'd be hitting the bottle
she worried and drank
worried and
drank oh boy oh
o what oh my God while he was away that
sucks there are some fine folks from the
Press waiting outside oh good your daddy
is doing the best he knows how but he is
overwhelmed he need your help out I
can't go up there I just want to stay
here forever talk about overwhelmed man
jeez from this moment on anything she
would have done I will carry out in her
name sure
Comfort your friends and your family and
even your
friends because if you don't do that all
that your mama has sacrificed for you
will be for nothing it'll be all your
fault
Dewey ouch from himself it's a tragic
transition my plan Elvis Presley would
return a clean cut all American
boy yeah here we go I did not consider
the most dangerous thing of
all what love could that of course
Priscilla the pretty teenage daughter of
the United States Air Force officer oh
goody of legal consenting age I'm
certain this guy he's got he's got girls
all over the world okay he's got girls
waiting outside of his house and girls
riding him endless fan mail listen okay
he's just really lonely and quite
frankly so am I
oh and then they didn't really know what
to say after that so they went upstairs
and they went to bed mik drop never met
anyone like you I hope not James Dean I
just hope that one day be as good as him
you'll get there you will be the James
Dean of Beach Blanket Bingo movies he
gonna say hash Austin Butler for James
Dean col promised me when I get back
he's going to set me up in Hollywood to
being a serious act really what I dream
of is that
true oh
oh and that perfectly framed flare you
no longer want to sing in your films is
that right you want to be a dramatic
actor oh cool that's my big ambition now
takes a lot of time no songs in any of
my films very cool good as brandoo who
his life became one big Hollywood
[Laughter]
movie
sure
wow buddies cousins his Memphis cousin
Billy
vas Diva Viagra and introducing baby
Lisa Marie oh Lisa Marie the highest
paid actor in Hollywood history damn we
had a lot of fun sure we did Mania sweep
America as team to the teen Rock oh no
getting overtaken by other current
events Dr Martin Luther King the Apostle
of nonviolence in the civil rights
movement has
[Music]
sh oh [__] we've seen Elvis the rebel
we've seen Elvis the movie start now we
will see Elvis the family Entertainer
it's all about adaptation oh good
adapting to times can I watch the
memorial with you might be getting ready
a little early this year as Tom Parker
is always about Christmas yeah so tired
of playing out this President too many
people are Li I love you and your
daughter loves you I love you too my
child
bride he you Jackson oh
boy that's the music makes me go forth
son you got to meet these bender and
Bones guys e they're the ones that put
James Brown Rolling Stones on stage
they're doing some cuttingedge stuff
whoa when I first came to Hollywood I'd
come up here and sit for
right over there The Observatory that's
where they shot Rebels out a cause it's
actually there little couple months ago
I really like what you guys did putting
James Brown and the stones together
we're uh big fans of yours too Mr
President we we don't usually Elvis uh
call me e dog call me EP tell me
honestly what do your boys think my
career is at right now yeah uhoh
honestly it's in the
toilet I knew you were the right guys
for this job sure back when I was I was
starting out some people wanted to put
me in jail even kill me cu the way I was
moving I killed my
mother s they been Wayward I need you
fellas to help me get back to who I
really am who are you all this freaking
King sure as hell ain't somebody who
sings Christmas songs about fireplace
for an hour and what does the colonel
think I don't give a damn what the
colonel thinks
oh free huh number one Hot Shot director
Elvis will be humoring him by doing a
few of his fresh ideas ah the sweater
for Mr Presley's dressing room please oh
yeah I love a good Christmas song but
yeah I just don't see Elvis doing that
if you want to find yourself first thing
you do is go home metaphorically you
know get back to who you really are
remember who you
are we get your old band back together
but we are going to start with here
comes Santa CLA I thought that was Z
for a sec I know it's not here's Elvis
Presley oh boy all black everything
we're going to have to send him back to
the Army again another couple years send
her to the Army in the
sweater
oh that red guitar on that black
[Music]
outfit valy and the Lonely Street
Heartbreak Hotel where I'll
[Music]
be I got to brush up my Elvis voice I
played the Pharaoh and Joseph in high
school all right next karaoke and I
we're doing Elvis
[Music]
yes my
baby yeah
[Applause]
ain't no friend of mine it's time for
here come Santa Claus I said so no no
first position oh my
god let's
rock
oh it's getting the women back on his
died that's that's right I feel like
they would do just about any if he
wanted to Galvanize them into a militia
he could they let me do what I want to
do sing the music that I want music that
I
love yeah those know all hippies had
brainwashed this of course they yeah did
definitely you did not brainwash
him
[Applause]
no wow those moves none of this will be
in the special can you make a note that
that should be in the special Jesus
Christ we've usurped your Authority go
they're going to get in like a fist
fight oh my God
what now bring in the Kung Fu
spectacular
yes what is happening this is real we
got to track this special
down
yes wow
whoa was that an LA
Hotel thinking the kitchen of an LA
hotel if I remember yes I know the name
damn is it the Ambassador the Ambassador
Hotel uh maybe already on
set God yeah that this nation is hurting
it's lost you know it it needs a voice
right now to help it heal you have to
make a statement
EP boy Mr Presley do that make
statements uh here we go poor Mrs
Kennedy tragedy but it has nothing to do
with us it has everything to do with us
sure we're all Americans do not think we
should be making speeches about politics
and religion Dr King was shot 8 miles
from Graceland while I was out here into
Turtles and all you can think about is
how many goddamn sweaters I can sell I
am a promoter that is what I do and I'm
El that's what I do oh boy colonel I
know when I've excited an audience that
was not a real audience my boy there was
a sign flashing applaud telling them
when to clap for you oh no listen to the
guy who had the movies flop for you the
last few now I have convinced our
friends at Singer sewing machines to
come back tomorrow for here com Santa
Clause oh Dr King said rock and roll
music contributed to juvenile
delinquency uh plenty of others will say
the same about hip hop couple decades
[Music]
later we're pretty set for the number
tomorrow right it's pretty familiar
territory ran once told me when things
are too dangerous to say sing Oh yes sir
solid advice it's the language of the
Ang's song he's working on a new song he
says he's singing it new song hey it's
beginning to look a lot like Christmas
yes oh my goodness you and I are on the
same page at last the lights on the sun
yep definitely sir you have no idea that
dang sweater ain't never going to make
it in here is
it
wow going to be your winner
Wonderland whoa that's trouble with
[Music]
pain but as long as a man has the
strength
sure I have definitely seen this image
Big Red Elvis text the white
[Music]
suit yes
ma'am Dam
yes he is back Elvis sings a protest
song that's how you speak to the nation
I always said when it came to music My
Boy Knows Best But the special was my
idea what what
what we was back on top but some people
were putting ideas into his head that he
didn't need me he's taking credit for
the special I love that I love that for
you Jesus Christ you do a week of shows
in just one night then when it's done
you get on the plane go where you want
play where you want we hope you enjoy
this flight don't forget to put your
seat belts on you know I heard last year
alone you had two offers Germany and
Japan for a million bucks damn Jesu
Chris we need to strike up a deal with
an airline yeah real rejects Airline
there we go do live reactions on the
plane yes everyone watching the same
movie this flight yes Mr con would like
to see you oh no Colonel bucker hit me
what rank are you man IIs called you
Admiral like 10 minutes ago I know
you're not even actually like in the
military I guess but I hear your boys
working with new people you've lost your
meal ticket yeah no passport no
residency you were never a colonel never
a Tom you weren even a Parker you
weren't even a Hanks you know what he's
like the second that you're near him
you'll be under 10 ft of snow before you
know what's happening yes I'm going to
go see him in Vegas I'm going look him
in the eyes I'm going tell him gambling
not for money tell but alive oh no man
are
you he's smoking a cigar as he in the
hospital that's a prescription cigar
yeah it's over the counter yeah oh my
boy I should have come down to see you
but I'm a little laid up you know just
had a heart attack you're not meant to
get out of bed let work on emotional
manipulation right now Colonel
absolutely he's a pro nobody can sell
show to an audience like you I admit it
I was wrong sell snow to an
audience oh boy oh boy we need to go
oh day love will find you he said it
well you may be right maybe it is time
for me to retire you hear the coins
falling and like chains ringing in the
background these International tours
very very expensive oh boy what are you
doing man fin would put a strain on your
daddy oh no what if the next Elvis
Presley show did not cost you a red
scent go
on if your daddy would not like the
sound of that a Dead's boy brand new
international hotel oh we get in Vegas
residency Elvis Mighty big stage biggest
in Las Vegas get lost in a place like
this sure like let me take you back to
that mirror room this International
Hotel needs a major drawing card to pull
in other the roofs and put it on the map
sure so they will cover all of the costs
of putting together your show and you
just play here for six weeks we can
bleed them dry oh boy to tour around the
world with no Financial Risk to Elvis
Presley Enterprises none oh my
God snowman strikes
again we're going to make it oh my God
can't get rid of him there was some
magic in that old Straw Hat they
say Flames
Flames I'll get back I'll get back
that
right oh the
power
yes a oh it is time Jesus Christ that's
all right that's all right you that's
all
right all
o flashing
back oh yeah he got that inlay man with
his name in The Pearl yeah or opal
whatever that
is
wowe Dam nice nice use of yeah I feel
like this movie has like smoothed out as
it goes along cuz with the editing and
the and the nonlinear storytelling yeah
and the pacing too I've gotten much more
used to it I tell you if I was you I
would book him for 100 years I would
book him for 100 of course you would but
we hear hulet has him doing a world tour
oh those were the guys he owed the money
to right I think Mr Presley could be
persuaded to make the international his
home provided he was paid pretty well
why did you have in mind one billion
dollar did they ink this contract on a
tablecloth that's how it
appears A Millie per year for five
years
dream on
suspicious
I finding contract I guess it is that is
what my boy would
expect what are you going to pay me ouch
dude what are they going to pay you
Colonel your Sid show is the
jackpot coming from a casino owner that
means a
lot yeah you knew that oh boy oh my God
plus
unlimited what now lines of credit line
of C Oh No
gambling oh
[Applause]
no yeah get them hips going boy
oh damn do whatever you want Colonel as
long as that boy stays on that
stage was that baz was that baz director
Cameo that guy in that Booth he was like
on the left side of the screen a couple
girls next to him sure looked like
him
oh make on Hanks are pretty good like
the the old age one in the wraparound is
the most obvious but oh oh that's bad I
saw in her face that night she could
never compete with the love he felt from
you
yeah with you and you and you and you
and you and you and you and
you damn I exerted a lot of energy yeah
it's exhausting such a fan show now are
you prepared to do this every day for
five years yeah and how many shows a day
is he going to do yeah that I'm that I'm
curious about you alone Rose above it
all you could work with your talent your
dedication sure
enough
did yeah you originally told him six
weeks and you get to go around the world
not five
years I can't wait to show the world
yeah I'm not the king hey F Mr F Domino
ladies and gentlemen real king of
sure
uhoh what are you looking at right oh he
ain't going to tell him till like
[Music]
it's this is Elvis Presley the most
famous man on the planet straight
yeah buddy Lord have mercy straight
razor to whoa keep throwing the mic
there jeez there is nothing more
important than
security damn dog whoa I'm going to kill
you
oh almost cut you in
half k only two kinds of people know
Kung Fu Chinese and the King those guys
turned out to be some OV excited fans
from Peru but
wow Elvis Presley has apparently checked
into a private Suite suffering from
exhaustion sure this was a wild time
like people be getting trampled at shows
like a lot more I think oh Sharon Tate
oh my God
jeez threatening killing popular
Entertainer the IRA blowing up England
planes exploding in midair has the world
gone mad it's a mad mad mad mad world
Lisa Marie's daddy will be safe while
he's away from home we're taking the
show of the world Colonel yeah oh how's
this going to end oh no we could do an
American tour 15 cities in 15 days while
Mr huet straightens out his security
problems overse like that we're in for
ex exhaustion 15 cities 15
[Music]
days not bad was good 15 times who
boy how does he have the energy to do
that 15 nights in a row snow Andrew snow
I understood that reference white powder
snow all in the safety of the
USFA
ah that tiger suit I brought the world
to him I invented the world's first ever
satellite concert
really 1.5 billion people in one night
damn oh my
God I love that that was good that split
screen was well choreographed he was
addicted to the love he felt from you on
stage AG I'm sorry I didn't mean it so
in the lonely moments between show and
Lisa Marie he turned to Dem pills yeah
Dem pills boy you get my baby
girl okay
ug oh man what was
that oh my God what he's got Badges and
[__] in there there no one going to walk
around say they K love this person what
did he say nothing
baby that is true and the reality will
be much more unfortunate than someone
paranoid than than being able to say
that I
guess Sharon T oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God you
don't I'm leaving you and I'm taking
Lisa with me yeah no I couldn't care
less about whoever it is you sneak
through the side door the
those leaches and speed down your throat
like you're strung out strung out God
damn I'm in the best shape of my
life ug what I want is a husband I am
your wife and Lisa is your daughter she
needs a father I am her father oh do you
remember the last time that the three of
us sat down on that dinner together Jes
W even make love to me anymore a you're
40 and I'm 50 we'll be back together oh
a okay St never leave you have to let me
go you have to you have to let me
go yeah why won't the colonel let him go
overseas security Jerry you know that
[__] that the Colonel's killing his
greatest asset without a reason so what
is the reason Colonel always has his
reasons he signed a napkin credit dead
assuagement there wasn't going to be an
international tour cuz he can't leave
the country he's got no citizenship no
official identity he doesn't exist there
never was a colonel Tom Parker damn what
are you talking about
J oh my
God get out of the
[Music]
way now you listen to me the only that
matters it's that that man gets up on
that stage tonight yeah
yeah if he was my son I put him in the
hospital of course this is a Presley
Enterprise's decision jeez dad come on
dad Step Up for your son father first
manager second what can you do for him
Dr Nick hi
everybody just a little pin
prick that'll get you going for the
show damn and then he falls over again
dude should be in the hospital right now
now that you seen me I'd like to take a
look at
you let me just want to take one last
look at you my socalled manager col Tom
par oh this about to become a roast but
I hear rumors that Colonel is an
alien somebody call the FBI and tell him
that he has abducted me that he has
locked me in this golden cage keep me
here
[Music]
forever cuz Colonel's got some big debts
baby o yep there's the truth I'm going
to get on my Jet Plane it's named after
my uh my beautiful daughter is he going
to still be alive after this show who's
it named after
again you know I'm going to fly away
stop Oh Glory I will fly
away w
Mr Shing what the devil is happening
here did they they find his napkin 800
shows you don't have a goddamn passport
you son of a
[__] fire oh my God this must have
happened you fired is this what really
went down the boy wants to set out on
his own it's all right by me but Presley
Enterprises is going to cough up what it
all oh my god oh
no
G yes all your expenses itemized and in
order what's the bill how
much well that is what we ow oh buddy
8.5 mil you spent so much money you know
you got the cars and the girls and the
clothes and all the you know new
airplane yeah we're playing broke got to
take the colonel back I'm not taking him
back oh Colonel you're rehired oh
God we're going to lose Grace not your
baby damn oh boy oh what a nightmare it
takes everything from me it takes 50% of
everything get I'll make and now we want
to take a home that we bought from M oh
yeah this to me
that old bastard can sue if he wants but
I am flying
away with or without you with or without
you
ah you bled me dry and you still want
more I'm not an uncaring man Mr Presley
don't you Mr Presley me you Toad oh you
Toad you still have your claws on me you
still have me working here like a
goddamn slave in assault mine you're
fing no good piece of trash I got to
shoot you in your fat Goddamn face damn
everyone else you associate with lives
from you even your own Daddy has looked
after himself before he's looked after
you yeah we have supported each other
because we share the dream sharing a
nightmare now we are the same you and I
we are two odd lonely children wow
Reaching For Eternity two odd lonely
children Reaching For
Eternity
picture Lonely at the Top boy and how
far to
fall waiting for that phone to ring yes
like when you coming back man I come
[Music]
back
me you
[Music]
I I will try be your dad I will try and
fix it yeah of course tell that son of a
[__] I want things to go back to the
way they were
yeah you kind of have no choice oh and
literally closing off from the outside
world
colel send up Dr Nick he's going to
collapse Jesus whole
resign it's a beautiful day in Las Vegas
with lots going on this weekend those
teen
sens the Jackson Five hey and it's
interesting too cuz one of them married
his daughter that's true yeah the most
famous of
themy is to OPP Barb in a remake of AAR
oh snap really you called it earlier so
let me get one last look at you won't be
much of a stretch for him to play the
role of a was singer thank you for that
I bet you I feel real proud of yourself
coming up with that that
[Music]
bar a little one I told you Richard
rockburg was Dracula and Van Elon he was
also in everyone's favorite Mission
Impossible film the second one the best
one objectively the best one he was sha
Ambrose's uh main henchman sure honey
there's this
place San Diego that you can go to rest
the San Diego Zoo SeaWorld I'm going be
sh 40 oh and nobody's going to remember
me never done anything lasting you can
rest easy on that one I never made that
classic film that I could be proud of
maybe not that one please go for Lisa a
if you dreaming do it baby yeah get your
life together
I'm on that a
dream that's heavy Great
Scott oh damn is that the last time
they're together I am afraid it could be
wonder if Priscilla Presley was a
consultant on this film at all the way
this is edited and
shotted and that line seems to indicated
is the last time they're going to be
together I will always love you I forgot
Lisa Marie passed away right I think she
did my memory is bad I know prisilla is
still love I
[Music]
think
oh oh
boy stock footage or with that yeah that
like stock footage you look the slow
frame rate you know there's a kind of
bird doesn't have any legs so I can't
land on nothing don't you know about the
bird everybody's heard about the bird
lives his whole life on the wi when he
gets tired it just sprs swings and
sleeps on the Wind
sure does land even but one time that's
why it dies damn Elvis Presley 42 wow
that's so young he was found at his home
in Memphis has just made a St Elvis
Presley's death deprives our country of
a part of itself he was unique and
irreplaceable damn it's so young a
lonely life ends what killed my
boy then doctors say it was his heart
you had a big Parton that if this movie
is accurate some say it was me sure know
I'll tell you what killed him it was you
the audience it was love his love for
you yeah guy has no accountability for
his actions a few weeks before he died I
saw saw him sing for the very last time
he could barely stand up but that night
he sang as he always did with all his
heart and soul how you like it so far oh
man he does not look good cocacola
[Music]
Elvis oh man
so
tragic show
enough oh
boy oh dude
God I guess it is the most consistent
and purest love he has experienced aside
from maybe that of his
wife oh he learned some of the
keys
wow me
sure oh is that the are we in real
footage now
[Music]
yeah when I was a child ladies and
gentlemen I was a dreamer I read comic
books and I was the hero of the comic
book a sure so every dream that I ever
dreamed has come true 100
times wow
damn I learned very early in life that
without a song the day would never end
without a song man got a friend without
a song The would never been without a
song so I'll keep singing a
[Music]
song yes sir
oh
yeah
[Music]
damn wow man oh my God damn how he must
have been feeling too in that moment to
still put on a show like that Jesus cuz
he did not look like he was in adequate
shape to be performing no it's only by
the virtue of the fact that his body is
like so so so steeped in that muscle
memory yeah and it's probably like the
one spark of inspiration he has at this
point to get through that day like
without the song where would the day
go whoa oh interesting choice
Colonel Parker's Financial abuse of
Elvis was finally exposed in a series of
lawsuits beginning a few years after of
course of course immunity as a citizen
Parker tried to claim immunity as a
citizen of no country but eventually
settled out of court ending his ties to
the Presley estate how much was that
settlement Colonel spent his fin years
in poor health wandering through Vegas
casinos good yeah that was in the
wraparound full circle bestselling solo
recording of all time Dam D I believe
it and it shall forever and ever damn
Michael Jackson like didn't out sell
him damn
1977 35 to
baz baz boy damn screenplay by a whole
bunch of people yeah right took a
village um by the way if you are
listening to us on Apple or Spotify if
you do not mind giving us a rating we
would so appreciate it and I know the
legend of Elvis would also appreciate it
the legend of el Elvis's ghost really
Cary thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video I've literally
just finished a therapy session and I
wanted to shoot this cuz I'm in this
state of knowing why I Champion mental
health support so much in the past few
weeks work's been a little bit hectic
it's led me to miss some sessions and I
really don't like doing that and
sometimes that's when weight really
starts to pile on a lot of restless
nights a lot of fatigue a lot of I can't
sleep even though I'm so tired sometimes
just a very deep-seated sense of Gloom
meditating and sometimes journaling are
my daily go-tos but sometimes they just
don't cut it when I'm trying to pinpoint
why I'm down and really especially after
a session like today therapy just really
helps clear the fog discussing the
feelings is a critical step for me
especially as someone who's diagnosed
with ADHD type 2 bipolar and PTSD it's
truly a Cornerstone in my well-being and
I'm not alone in this many of us here at
real rejects are in therapy facing our
own challenges from depression to
anxiety or just needing a non-judgmental
space to voice our thoughts this year
I've been working on most days of the
week to keep my physical health strong
and I really do Champion therapy as a
way to strengthen my mental resilience
and for many betterhelp is integral to
that process There's real value in
better help's accessible and adaptable
service they match you with a licensed
therapist and provide the option to
switch if necessary ensuring the right
fit for your mental health Journey as
this year winds down and we confront
life's complexities do consider
betterhelp as a resource really happy to
be partnered with them this month so you
can go to betterhelp.com rejects for 10
% off your first month again that's b t
r
hp.com slre rejects so join us in moving
forward stronger together thank you
again thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner and Ecommerce you don't need to
be Tex have to understand it allows
individuals and businesses to create and
manage online stores offering tools for
sales payments marketing and inventory
management it's worth trying out because
of its userfriendly interface extensive
customization options comprehensive of
Suite of features that cater to
businesses of all sizes their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us empowers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
their war-winning support always there
to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all overc case shopify.com rejects start
your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team I must
say like first and foremost I think this
is the obvious thing to say Austin
Butler was oh yeah it was terrible suck
dude hated the performance performance
he is not convincing at
all I kept on seeing Austin the whole
time I could not see he was he was
phenomenal I I really like I mean you
could tell how much he seed to this
performance I mean uh not to get into a
compare game but like I would say I
would put him on the level of uh it's
been a while since I've seen the movie
but the film The Doors with Val Kilmer
sure he I mean Val Kilmer like just took
it to another level in that film and I
would say same thing with Austin Butler
in this film like I mean he he's Elvis
um he's just phenomenal I love the
journey we go through with this
character you know just from and again
it took me a little bit at the beginning
just the style of editing and the
nonlinear storytelling but once the film
uh once we got a little more into the
film I was like okay I'm a little more
on board here um because Buzz lman I
mean to his credit he's got a specific
style of how he likes to make films
which again let's see Richard rockburg
he's got a specific style like how he
likes to make films and again I respect
that I want all filmmakers to make films
the way they want to you know um not to
be beholden to you know Studios we don't
want them to be like what happened to
Elvis uh here uh you know how he was
unfortunately and you know is
interesting too because I didn't know
and I know people are going like how do
you not know this I'm sorry I'm call me
ignor or whatever I just knew who Elvis
was I just knew how great his songs are
I didn't know any of this Colonel Parker
I had no idea any of this stuff so like
I mean I was grateful to find out about
all this although also too like that
sucks like I mean and that's like that's
that can be the hores of humanity too of
just like people using you for personal
and financial gain and it was awful and
obviously there were times like you know
the oh we're oh is this Shazam what's
going on here oh oh it's just the logo
sure um I mean there were Times
Obviously where like you the colonel did
help him in terms of financial gain but
overall like he was using him and it was
awful how he used him and obviously like
you know that's a big part of like you
know just what let out of his heart and
just like he didn't give a damn about
him he just what he brought to the table
is all he gave a damn about and you know
I just um what I loved too about Elvis
was just like you know he he was a good
person at heart and like you know he
didn't see color in terms of like when
there was s such racial
Divi when there was such racial divides
in the country and all that and like and
also too cuz he grew up at it you know
in the neighborhoods uh and um I
appreciated that and um I love that like
at the end of the day like his soul and
his life was music and that's what he
could come back to at the end of the day
and that's where he spoke his soul and
his voice through and I love that I
thought that was just such a beautiful
message to carry through I got more to
say but Johan what do you got to say
about the
film yeah man I agree uh I mean
absolutely this movie when it was first
coming out and everything and they were
dropping trailers like that was the
first I had ever heard about Colonel Tom
Parker uh in any yeah like I I only knew
the The Bare Basics about Elvis's story
in general you know I've seen a couple
of his old movies on Turner Classics or
whatever I've heard some of his biggest
songs but I don't have any deep cut
knowledge of his catalog I don't have
any knowledge of his history really so
this in a lot of ways is a big primer
aren't there a lot of Elis movies this
made me curious to to check out me too
um and and yeah I mean I think it's it's
an interesting story they draw here
because obviously Tom Parker is the
saleri presented in this you know
iteration and uh and and I think there
is something interesting to that like
yes I I think it certainly seems that he
was an opportunist and he was a bit of a
of a Huer but um at the same time I
don't know like it's it's a fascinating
little thing to ponder because again I
don't
again like I'm going to have to go look
at footage of the actual guy and kind of
you know read further into that because
it's one of those things where I believe
that there is some kind of like
affection there or something but it is
Tainted by The Leverage and the greed
and the that snow business that he keeps
on talking about like I think there is a
part at least as illustrated by this of
Tom Parker that does you know kind of
crave some kind of love and and
admiration and gratitude for what he's
able to do and like it poses the
question of what would Elvis's career
become if he hadn't had Tom Parker if he
had other people if he was making his
own decisions if like this is so many
it's one of those fascinating Chronicles
of like so many points of no return
where you know if he had just left and
you know started working with these
other people at this time solely or if
he had taken full control of this you
know this time solely what would that
have looked like so I think it's a it's
a very fascinating portrait here and
yeah Elvis does get a lot of criticism
in culture for being a culture vulture
as they say and that's something that I
also don't know a heap ton about and I
think the movie here like that's
something that I I still would like to
you
know examine some kind of Deep dive into
compiled by somebody who obviously you
know has researched this fully I like
that the movie at least acknowledges and
like I didn't know at all that he grew
up in like a a black neighborhood and
and you know like they were you know
poor enough his family that they had to
move out of you know White Society into
black society and and that certainly to
me speaks to a greater authenticity in
terms of where that inspiration comes
from because there's a lot of
appropriation in rock and roll music and
and a whole bunch of you know other
styles of popular music that is stemming
from the blues and gospel and soul and
and Rhythm rhythm in blues and all sorts
of other things a lot of black music and
and Jazz definitely and you know I
thought they did a nice job of at least
acknowledging that that's part of his
roots uh you know I think it would have
been interesting to spend more time with
some of those like we we spend a little
with BB King we see sister Rosetta Tharp
a few times but like to actually spend
some intimate time with them would have
been interesting and I think you know
they they do at least touch on the idea
that you know here and there he does
sort of directly acknowledge the culture
that inspired him but I think there are
also arguments on the other side that he
could have probably done a whole bunch
more in that respect you know to really
Elevate those musicians and to Aid in
the pursuit of civil rights uh so like
in that sense I feel like the movie is
is a bit gloss or a bit vague it's just
it's not doing that stuff so much it's
not about the the uh uh racial cultural
socio impact of Elvis so much as it is
yeah about the rise the fall the life
the times and as such uh yeah I thought
this was fascinating and it definitely
smoothed out as it went along because I
think Bas lurman the more we go like I
like Bas lurman style generally but you
know as time goes he definitely has a
unique and very sort of break neck kind
of style about him the way shots are cut
and uh composed in just like these
swooping camera angles and like the
immense Glitz Glamour and opulence of
everything and I think that easily suits
this person this character this figure
in history um and yeah like as a movie
like when we first started cuz baz
lurman is almost like uh Wes Anderson to
me in that like their style is so
particular and specific that it can
easily fall into parody if it's not
careful and at the beginning I was like
whoa we are [__] rocking rocketing
through this and it was hard for me to
keep TR yeah this movie is on coke right
now and uh and and I thought as it went
along and especially as you get into act
to it started to have actual scenes and
and
breathe appropriately in counterbalance
to its sense of kineticism and its sense
of Glitz and all that stuff yeah no I
feel you um you know you asked you
brought up an interesting point uh you
know about if Colonel Parker had never
come into his life you know how how
would it all of
unfolded and we still did see that he
kind he really had a spending problem
you know like with the the pills and the
women and all that and the Entourage
that he took care of so I still think
that would have been an issue because I
think you know as and not to get too
much off topic but like I think like a
big thing in our education system that
would help is like having a financial
understanding of how we should you know
take care of our our money but we spent
so much time in school on stuff that we
ought to at least trade a little bit of
that time for like the basics of how to
get by in societ right of course but so
I mean but you know from but I think you
did pose an interesting question like
how would his career have turned out but
it would have been nice that if he would
have had like a manager that really gave
a like I I know you said it was kind of
like um you know he did kind of care
about him but it was more opportunist
type of like it seems like he wants a
son like seems like a lonely guy is like
divorced he has country he has a du he
kind of like
Tommy I swear really quick before you go
on I swear as a joke and I was like I
don't know if this is appropriate to say
I was going to say he's he's Tommy wio I
was going to say it like two or three
times during the film because he's got
no identity but I'm sorry continue on
he's got no identity he's got like the
the mystery sort of like Eastern
European but like from everywhere kind
of accent and and that's another thing
is a
is I've heard a lot of criticism about
Tom hanks's performance sorry I'm doing
my Elvis costume my dad did not like his
performance he actually told me U
yesterday when I told him we were going
to react to this yeah and that's I think
a common thing I hear about this movie
is that what were they thinking with Tom
Hanks and this crazy makeup and and this
it feels like the most caricatured
aspect and I don't I don't completely
disagree but I actually Eno I would he
Blended more I was less distracted by
him than I expected to be it felt less
of a meme than I expected it to and I
think the height of Bas lurman style
helps the performance along and I think
a lot of the makeups are pretty good you
the the most obvious one is is in the
wraparound when he's in the you know
Casino Palace of the Mind reflecting on
all this stuff but yeah like he's a guy
with no ties to anywhere and in a
certain way I feel like he's living a
unique American dream of this place in
time where he's not even like on the
record but he's traveling around he
knows Showbiz he knows how to hustle and
you know growing from the carnival into
yeah like there's certainly tons of
exploitation and conniving but I think
the tragedy and the interesting thing is
that you do get to sit there and wonder
you know and I think posing him as the
unreliable narrator is an interesting
choice because yeah I'm sure a lot of
people do directly as he says know blame
him for all of this and I think what
they're getting at in the ending
monologue there is kind of that all of
it you know in life it's probably all
these factors are you know contributing
and I yeah think that Tom Parker
especially with the debts especially
with like trapping him in this residency
and and you know not only assuage debts
but unlimited lines of credit like
there's definitely exploitation but I
also get the sense or at least from how
this movie's playing everything that he
does want to be a father figure to like
he seems to get something whether it's
like genuine I think he thinks it's
genuine that he wants this father son
and and you trust me like I protect you
I provide for the both of us you trust
me more than anybody and I'm just here
to empower your talent and there are
yeah bits and pieces of that that feel
authentic even though the whole thing is
yeah to your point like after uh Elvis's
mother passed away when he spoke to him
in the way he spoke to him in the uh the
closet I mean like the dad even said
like Richard rockburg his actual dad
said I can't talk you got to talk to him
like he trusts you more than he trusts
me so yeah and so much of your life has
been in business has been in performance
has been on stage like like Tom Parker
Colonel Parker the Admiral whatever you
want to call him is in a better position
to guide and mentor and understand this
kid than his actual father is right
right yeah yeah and also too he was also
able to you know manipulate him at at
any which way I mean every time Elvis
thought that he finally was able to get
rid of him he's like okay I'm going to
tell him at the hospital all right all
right and now I'm going to just show him
up at the international I'm done with
this guy you get the you know for well
after he was done at the hospital then
he comes up with the deal at the
international when he was done with him
at the international then he gives him
the $8.5 million thing it's like this he
could not get rid of this guy it was
literally a parasite for him um so yeah
yeah it was again I don't know how exact
cuz obviously we know in films like even
when it's a biopic there's going to be
certain things that they hollywoodized
truncation of course so I don't know
exactly how accurate this is but if fits
pretty accurate it's interesting and
crazy at the at the same time but it
compels you to want to go out and learn
more and I appreciate of all the biopics
I've seen recently I mean yeah there
there is structure certainly but I
wasn't and I know I made a good amount
of Walk Hard jokes but I I wasn't too
distract like it's hard to make a biop
piic in a post to walk Hard world
because especially music biopic like
Walk Hard just just left no stone
unturned and so I think nowadays
especially you have to almost run
yourself like like I remember the Russo
Brothers said that thing about like we
try to make our Marvel movies honest
trailer proof I feel like for a biopic
you have to make your movie Walk Hard
proof and and you know I'm not going to
say that this fully reinvents the wheel
but this did sweep me up into its
atmosphere and its world and I thought
that baz lurman was a solid choice for
this figure and the Aesthetics that you
know he would eventually embody
especially as he gets to Las Vegas yeah
and and yeah the cast across the board
did a great job the costumes are
terrific uh the way they transport you
back in time the blending of you know
stock photos and stock footage with you
know what is being Rec created on screen
and all that stuff I thought that was
nicely Chosen and yeah like again Austin
Butler as far as yeah as far as these
kinds of performances go you know it's
such a towering thing and it got so much
praise and and recognition but I I do
feel like watching this I forgot I was I
didn't fully forget because obviously
you're aware that you're watching a
historical thing but like there were
times when I wasn't focused on or or
even thinking about how this translates
as an impression or impersonation just
yeah just I I lost myself in watching
the character and I think that's a good
thing and I think that's what you need
in a in a role like this and I think
this is a particular like I think there
are two Paths of difficulty when it
comes to portraying a real life figure
and it's like you have certain figures
that are very subtle in their mannerisms
and that's hard to nail down and then
you have other characters who are very
specific in their voice and mannerisms
such as Elvis and I think he he towed
the line really nicely of like you got
to sound like him you can't do one of
those things where it's like you know a
a a a spiritual portrayal rather than
like a direct portray so like yeah I
thought that was nicely handled and I
would be curious to hear Tom Parker like
receive footage of him just to see what
the representation is there cuz that's
the thing about this movie I think is
you have this weird yin and yang of like
you have such an immersive portrayal of
one historical figure and then one
performance that again saved for me
largely by just I don't know Tom hanks's
natural Charisma and the you know
overwhelming nature of the style of the
movie but at the same time yeah it's
this really real natural
performance pitted against this like
off-the-wall almost like it is like more
of a cartoon than anything else and you
have yeah this huge makeup and you're so
aware that's the funny thing is like I
lost Austin Butler a lot of the time yes
whereas Tom Hanks you're kind of always
aware of like it's Tom Hanks it's Tom
Hanks make and I don't know if this is
the guy like in the moment I'm sitting
here going well you know he's we don't
know exactly where he's from they say
his actual name at one point you know
clearly he's he's from elsewhere in the
world and trying to make it in the
American dream and so I could see how
whatever his natural accent would have
been would be uh sanded down and maybe
intentionally so to appear more
All-American or whatever so like like
I'm jury's out in terms of that aspect
cuz like if we were to hear real footage
and be like damn the voice is nothing
like that then you know I would have
more reservation right I mean then I
have never heard real footage of the
real Colonel Parker so I had nothing to
judge it or base it off like you I think
when my when I spoke to my dad yesterday
like he he knows the history he knows
Elvis very well in terms of again the
history and he has heard Colonel Parker
so I think when he watched the movie
that's that's where the criticism came
from when he said cuz obviously my dad
is loves it's so weird cuz yeah I didn't
hate the performance and it didn't wreck
the movie for me but didn't bother me
that much couldn't really argue anybody
out of those feels yeah yeah of course
of course it's understand like I I
totally understand the criticisms but
again having not heard Colonel Parker
before not knowing him or like it was
less yeah without that context it was
less distracting I thought it would be
based on what I'd heard and two uh sorry
I I know we we going all over the place
but I also liked and this is something
baz does and I think it rils people or
people object to it a bit more in
situations like this when it is a period
piece or it's directly historical but I
did appreciate the music flourishes both
and how they Incorporated Elvis's music
between the songs you really know the
songs that were re-recorded from other
artists and the songs that are just in
his deep Cuts catalog but also the way
that they would mix in in true baserman
fashion modern music flourish at times
or score elements at times taking
certain songs that you know for being
one mood and then adding score elements
so they're a bit uneasy or a bit more
tense uh to draw out that irony or you
know needle dropping in and kind of
mashing up like I think there's like a
DOA cat needle drop at some point in
there um you know there and and that is
something I could see people being
pulled out by but in that particular
scene when he's again I think he's like
going back to the part of town where he
sees BB King and all that stuff and and
you know the people are out in the
streets and there's a Vibrance and
there's a livelihood and I think using
modern touches like that actually I can
I get why people object to it and I
still couldn't fully argue you out of it
but I think in a situation like this or
or I'd be curious to go back and look at
the his Great Gatsby um because like
yeah when the modern music touches come
in I thought they enhanced a mood and
did a a nice kind of tangental thing of
like this is sort of the vibe of now as
it would have been then or here's the
vibe then and here's something to kind
of give you a touchstone or or evoke how
it might be now with some you know
current popular music or whatever yeah
it did take me a moment to like catch up
like oh we're contemporary music here
you hear some trap beats and you're like
what's going on here but also you know
again in the mood of that I was like but
I kind of get it and I kind of like it
for sure for sure but uh yeah know and
again last thing uh I just again I I
thought Austin Butler great job I love
that he was also able to embrace not
only the sounding like Elvis but the way
he moved just really like uh showing the
beautiful side of Elvis and also the
tragic side just really appreciated his
wonderful performance um do you have any
final thoughts you want to say Good
Golly this was so much of a movie if we
forgot anything let us we'll just go in
the comments and write an essay for you
exactly but uh let us know in the
comment section what did you think of
this fil film uh I don't know how many
other Buzz lman films you have seen I
have not seen too many I've seen Romeo
and Juliet now I've seen this one I
can't think of uh anything else I guess
I've seen the ending of Mulan Rouge if
that have I seen I know I've seen Mulan
Rouge that's the one I I have not seen
Australia but if there's any other
Australia baby they're back freaking
Nicole Kidman and and H Jackman are back
in austral I have not also seen Great
Gatsby so if there are any Buzz alarm in
films that you'd like John myself anyone
on the the rest of the real reject team
to react to or any other films let us
know in the comment section what you
think of this film what do you think of
Austin Butler's performance and more
importantly Tom Hank performance we'd
love to hear from you guys and Until
Then John and I have left the building
oh thank you thank you very much thank
you very
much Andrew Hayes I make this joke often
about how you probably just left your
card on file and haven't
checked I don't think it's a joke man I
think it's probably real you are
non-existent in our lives never sign up
for Rocket money don't find out that you
still have subcription G our fat my
money to these guys for so long and
they've been saying the same [__] every
single month about how my card's been
unfiled they Haven been bothered to
notify me it's only happening until you
speak out and let us know got demand a
better grade of joke man I I don't know
where I have no idea of at all of your
whereabouts you could be dead for all I
know it could be off the grid you could
be dead you could be like living in a
seminary somewhere as a monk they say
ignorance is bliss so as long as your
family does not notify us we will gladly
keep accepting the patreon pledge every
single month because I just imagine that
you're out on an island somewhere like
you know kicking back sipping some
umbrella drink money is no object to you
and this is just a drop in the bucket
that you use as a tax wrer that's
exactly what I'm thinking I think it's
just a write off somehow you're able to
write off this pledge is like a charity
donation sure yeah well you know he's
made YouTube videos before so that means
we're in a similar Lane and thus this is
supporting his industry by contributing
you know I hope so yeah so this pointy
man make it work for you something's
something's up I have no idea where you
where you've
been one of us definitely didn't steal
your identity you remember when we met
him he was like like he said he was
short he was like really short you know
like oh you didn't actually prepare me
for how short you were going to be spent
20 minutes just yelling his name and not
seeing where he was calling back from
until I finally realized I thought that
you were lost in the woods when you were
responding to me from my knees yes what
is the spirit who speaks to me now there
was a haunting happening yeah I met your
mom and and I was like oh she's just as
tall as him so I was like okay that
makes sense but is your dad also really
small
very C I thought about that I haven't
asked you maybe his dad is like really
really tall maybe he's like 6 foot1 well
it's like you know they're locksmith and
I imagine that he's probably good at
like picking locks and figuring out
because it meets his eyeline
sure definitely it's that it's
definitely that he gets the best view
know just he sees you're you're cut out
for this work is is right there you are
Made for This see I don't even know if
we've offended you cuz you probably have
no idea you've gotten this shout out and
then watch Andrew now has grown like a
whole foot and a half and like has put
on like tons and tons of muscle yeah and
then he could like beat the [__] out of
us
now he probably just sits there working
out in like that giant room of like his
like office chair and like 45 computers
is just playing his shout outs he's just
collecting shout outs call me short one
more time say the thing about my card
being on file and me forgetting one more
time in all seriousness though um I hope
you're well and I hope you never
unpledge even if we shut down this page
you're R I hope somehow hope somehow you
find a way to
sck we love you you're a part of the
fabric of this year happy New Year
[Music]
buddy